we have breaking news coming out of the
bitcoin conference today tesla square
and block stream all teaming up to
actually go ahead and build a
solar-powered bitcoin mining facility in
texas that's right elon musk jack dorsey
and cypher punk adam back all coming
together and bringing their
organizations to build a renewable
bitcoin mining facility now this is a
big big deal because there's been a ton
of people with all kinds of esg foot and
so we can now use solar power and
battery technology from tesla and then
we can combine it with square and block
streams bitcoin prowess and mining
technology all of a sudden we can prove
that the critics are wrong and so if we
go ahead and we take a look we've got a
quote right here from adam back himself
in which he states this is the step to
proving our thesis that bitcoin mining
can fund zero emission power
infrastructure and build economic growth
for the future we then have a quote from
the esg lead at block formerly known as
square where he says by collaborating on
this full stack 100 solar powered
bitcoin mining project with block stream
using solar and storage technology from
tesla we aim to further accelerate
bitcoin synergy with renewables and of
course if you think about what's really
happening here jack dorsey tweeted
earlier and he said from sunshine to
bitcoin that's exactly what they're
going to do they're going to try to
build a bitcoin mining facility that
uses that solar power that renewable
energy if they are successful in doing
what is really looks like a pilot
program today
my guess is that they'll ramp up
production they'll go ahead and build
out more infrastructure they'll build a
bigger and bigger facility and then
they'll try to replicate this in every
place that the sun shines
ultimately bitcoin mining is driving
renewable r d
what we are watching is a renaissance of
this type of energy production maybe it
works maybe it doesn't but i wouldn't
bet against elon musk jack dorsey and
adam back
bitcoiners are winning and it's because
they continue to innovate they continue
to experiment and they continue to put
their money where their mouth is hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time